Speaker 1: You have a Trump ally by the name
of Matt Brainard, who says that they're going
back to the Capitol.
He appeared on Steve Bannon's podcast last
week where he said, quote, As we continue
to raise the profiles of these individuals,
talking about the people who are arrested
and capital riot, it makes it harder and harder
for the left's phony narrative about an insurrection
to stick.
We're going to push back on the phony narrative
that there was an insurrection and they have
scheduled a justice for J. 6TH rally in D.C.
for September 18th.
September 18th is the date that he gave on
Steve Bannon's podcast.
Now, he says that he has gone through he's
gotten this whole thing approved, according
to what he said during this interview.
This is a planned rally that is going to take
place, he also says he totally has lawmakers
signed up that are going to, you know, come
and speak at this little event.
Of course, he won't tell us who they are yet.
But, you know, if I had to make a guess as
to the kind of people that would speak at
this, perhaps a Mo Brooks of Jim Jordan, Matt
Gates, Marjorie Taylor, Green Lawn, Bobert,
those kind of seem like the folks that would
be drawn to an event like this.
Of course, time will tell.
He, again, has not released their names.
He says they will once they're totally confirmed
to the event.
But, folks, we now have a date.
We have a date of when they're going back
to Washington, D.C., September a 10th.
That's the day that they've planned and this
is supposed to be just the big rally to raise
awareness.
About the conditions of the people who were
arrested, but here's the other part of this
story, folks.
We have seen both Matt Gates and Marjorie
Taylor Green and I believe Jim Jordan was
with him as well.
Make a spectacle of themselves as they always
do, trying to go into the jail where some
of these January six defendants are being
held.
Now, they didn't have preclearance.
They didn't have an appointment.
They showed up with a film crew knowing they
were going to be shoved away because you can't
just do that.
And then they tried to use that as some kind
of justification that, oh, obviously the conditions
these people are being held in are so terrifying
they won't let us in.
There is no evidence at all.
To suggest that any of these individuals are
being treated inhumanely or unfairly while
they're waiting in prison, OK, no evidence
exists to suggest any of that.
So let's get that very clear right now, the
people pushing that are the ones who, I guess,
have a vested interest in getting people to
think that bad things are happening to these
individuals because I don't know, maybe they
get to have more people show up at the rally
if they think that these people are being
held in inhumane conditions or if that they're
somehow being treated unfairly.
But again, don't get sucked into those lies
because there is no evidence to suggest that
any of this is actually happening.
It is a political talking point.
It is a political stunt.
It is pure theater.
So don't buy into it.
But what we do obviously have to be concerned
about is last time we had a gaggle of these
folks show up in Washington, D.C., it ended
in the January six Capitol riot.
Now you can call it a riot if you want.
You can call it an insurrection.
You can call it a failed coup.
Call it whatever you want.
You know, terminology we can quibble over
all day long.
And it's a pointless conversation.
The fact of the matter is, these people showed
up there on January 6th, broke into the Capitol,
smashed windows, broke down doors, multiple
people on both sides, the police officers
and the individuals who stormed the Capitol
dead from this.
We don't need another show like that, we don't
need something like this to happen again.
So I hope the authorities are taking this
seriously not to go down there and bust them
up if they've got permits for it.
Hold your rally.
It's going to be filled with lies.
And I hope nobody walks out of there actually
thinking anything you're saying is true.
But if you've done the due diligence, if you
filed the paperwork, you have a right to assemble
and nobody should infringe upon that.
We just got to make sure that D.C. is protected
and that these individuals don't once again
fall victim to the lies of charlatans who
know what they're saying is false.
Oh, and by the way, always happen to disappear.
Before things get too rowdy, you know, so
they can say, oh, I wasn't even there for
that, I was just there for the rally.
Yeah, they throw you folks under the bus.
Remember that if you travel to D.C. for that,
September 18th, justice for June six rally.